este camarógrafo aficionado tiene a las
tropas rusas en su punto de mira que
avanzan hacia boro dianca a 40
kilómetros de kiev cuando de repente
uno de los tanques joad ucraniano que se
refugia tan rápido como puede otros
vídeos verificados por la redacción de
los observadores muestran la devastación
del bombardeo jarquín especialmente en
sus zonas residenciales un residente que
da inconsolable frente a una víctima en
el suelo la sangre y la nieve se
entremezclan mientras las sirenas de los
bomberos dan paso a los sollozos de los
niños
el día
los rusos y ucranianos también están
luchando en gerson cerca de crimea en
este vídeo verificado por los
observadores de france 24 la plaza de la
libertad se parece a la plaza de
tiananmen un hombre ondea banderas
ucranianas frente a los tanques rusos
otros se unen a él para desafiar a los
soldados del kremlin
[Música]
en kiev las sirenas siguen sonando
los residentes escondidos en los
pasillos del metro excavan decenas de
metros bajo tierra el asedio pesa sobre
la moral de todos 80 hay fuertes
bombardeos la torre de televisión junto
a esta estación ha sido atacada la gente
está preocupada pero los trabajadores
del metro nos están ayudando mucho
trayendo agua y comida se podría decir
que este refugio es más o menos cómodo
pero todos tienen miedo especialmente
los niños pequeños el miércoles por la
noche sonó una explosión cerca de la
estación de tren de kiev tras lo que las
autoridades temen un fallo en la
calefacción de la ciudad en la que es
habitual estar por debajo de los cero
grados celsius